nella city ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo tornati
su paranormal dopo tipo mesi che non lo
facevo non vedevo l'ora di riprovarci la
cosa che mi ha sorpreso di più
appena acceso il gioco proprio e che
manca il menu pazzo è finito al menù
perfetto ragazzi ci siamo dopo
buongiorno insomma che beffa da quant'è
che non ti vedo zio allarga queste leggi
e gigio per chi non lo conoscesse mio
amico allora in poche parole vi spiego
questo gioco dovrebbe essere una roba
dove l'avevo già fatto solo che l'hanno
aggiornato quindi non so nulla di quello
che hanno messo a perché non l'ho capito
bene cosa è successo comunque no no non
ho già fatto una cosa sbagliata perfetta
io io continua il buio perché sono pazzo
in fondo quindi volevo che bella stato
tra lou reed massardo di meco sapevo lo
sapevo ci avrei scommesso lou reed ostro
madonna quanto sei sexy in una statua
che appena tentato di uccidermi cosa
molto normale cosa facciamo rossa cioè
della roba rossa che non capisco cos'è
luca fucking giusto vediamo di scoprire
chiediamo hanno aggiunto perché voglio
vedere che hanno combinato la gamma
prima cosa il cap questo non deve mai
mancare perché prima il caffè poi tutto
il resto perché se no non è possibile
la spesa è comprato del latte una pietra
è una banana giusto pio le camere uil
del sud
manuela frizzo e coordinato tranquillo
top 24 formaggi grazie senza cipolla il
cazzo dice regata ha fatto due passi
stanzi mando io ho tanto c'è il alla
resistenza di topo gigio gigio che cazzo
ci fai
io io lo sapevo che era lui che allora
tu devi smetterà di chiudere le porte di
metterti davanti alle porte
perché questa è casa mia mi fai uno
scherzo della madonna mica giuro che ti
prende più piccole il fuoco che ci sta
in gara
gli otto avvertito sia i barili che
quello stronzo di merda si sono messi
d'accordo io sono convinto che gli uni
saprò prima che succede di tutto quindi
c'è ancora telecamera lasciamo perdere
perché mi si sta scaricando la
videocamera che devo andare a dormire
per ricaricare la batteria quindi vado a
dormire e vedo che mi succede domani
anche presse tu sei lì per certi atti fa
vedere le riprese lissimo green il cane
si in groppa ad una sedia mentre io l'ho
pagata la bolletta della luce non
rompete i [ __ ] non so perché si
muove lampadario ma non lo voglio sapere
ragazzi non sa cosa delle telecamere che
vuoi vedere in hotel terrificante non
voglio nemmeno guardare vecchiato che il
grande successo che noi due siamo fermi
ok perché c'è una scarsa catalogo gigio
che cazzo e fa figo ben 320 riguardarmi
come lo sguardo sexy parte non ci cado
infront italy che lo fai con tua sorella
fuori dalla mia camera lo ridice cosa
stai facendo andare a dormire era un
sogno ma [ __ ] io che pensavo
chissà cosa non sogni e basta io io sono
buongiorno e un tizio bello fuori dalla
mia finestra salvere non lo so io questo
ma miss via di notte ma non è un maniaco
me ne vado di boa prima che succeda
succedano robe siamo in bagno ma per
farmi lava la faccia perché di prima
mattina non si può to peace totò visto
ho visto a parte lo specchio posseduto
al tizio e miss piani notte vediamo di
uscire prima che è prima che compaia
qualcuno ti brutto perché non so che c'è
chi già attaccato a una cross no vabbè
lasciamo bene
mi stai prendendo per il culo successo
al lampadario che prima si è mosso
non si sa perché sì perché si è mostrato
un pò a dario prima non l'ho capita sta
cosa
[Musica]
gj fatto un terzo aspetto molto gentile
cra grazie a quel monache sbatte le
porte non ho capito che c'è chi è che
sbatte la porta non importare un'ora
pensi così si aspetta la che la casa è
cattiva mi fa piacere però non gigio lo
è di più avanti da sto vicino alla porta
c'è un tasto vicino al pomello si chiama
campanello tulo premi eviti di rompere i
[ __ ]
ma lasciamo perdere tutto il resto è
tana gigia smettila che mi si sta
esaurendo la batteria devo tornare su
merda devo andare a dormire veloce
veloce maledizione perché dovrà così
provate cazzo perché guardi gigio e non
mi sto toccando recava a lui
polo non lo sapevo di essere superman
questa è una novità
bellissimo ok
giuro ha avuto la stessa nazione
guardando i compiti di matematica
allora ragazzi con invece possiamo a te
ne andare a ricaricare la batteria
perché sono fisco malissimo e l'altro
piove se prima non più aveva messo viene
fuori piove fantastico amico mio ci sono
le scale ok lo so che è molto difficile
imparare a salire le scale posso capirlo
per oh mio dio provaci almeno avvenuto
in bagno stavolta c'è qualcosa di
decente spero allora calmo è calmo ha
fatto preso ho visto ho visto lo ridotta
vista torniamo indietro perché c'è
michael jackson sulle pareti gigio 6
giocandolo contatore evita di prendermi
per il culo con le luci perché son cazzi
tuo aiuto lo dico che chi o cosa acceso
la televisione di preciso cioè magari
qualche programma decente maledizione a
picco e questo è un programma
eravamo arrivati più o meno qui lo meno
inciampato su uno sgabello solo io
riesco mamma mamma se duetti e
performance
che cazzo è successo non può
no no evitate di farvi prendere certi in
parti perché cos'era quella roba
attaccata al muro prima perché il
settore morivi porte che si aprono tra
il luglio 2011 fanta che poi come si fa
a caricare la batteria mentre dormi
ancora un mister tod's slip non dormi
oddio allora se non è chiaro io dormo
quando e dove cazzo mi pare ok perché
qua non ci chiariamo sennò non sapevo
cazzo lo so perché regala facciamoci la
barba fuori di qui subito non ne posso
sempre a chi cazzo è questa riavvia via
girate nonna non si muove non si muove
si muove buongiorno se fosse un te se
fosse un tempo non lo faccio il death
perfetto e calza successe a me michael
michael è vista ragazzina villa vista
anche michael g
quanti gigi ci sono già un nome ne
bastava ma non rompe del cazzo tutti
quanti insieme
o tu stai lì o tu stai lì non c'è mai
altra alternativa ok
[Musica]
buongiorno madame le preparo un caffè un
qualcosa non lo so come desidero è la
teiera va a [ __ ] anche quella ci
mancava solo questa
ragazzi la batteria non dura una sega
dovranno più di più le batteria
dell'iphone mio dio togliti togliti dai
[ __ ] perché finisci male te l'ho già
detto io te l'ho detto è youtube a
dormire a dormire velocci ok ci siamo di
nuovo prima che è un marchio luglio
visto già sveglio ho già sbagliato
buongiorno senta lei e non ha gran [ __ ]
questo io devo dire ha delle bellissime
mani per carità però mi lascia a
scendere grazie nostro sentire molto
gentile
gentilissima azzano sono morto o giusto
sa quante volte mi è capitato di andare
a dormire trovare dei [ __ ] che
mi volevano e mi ammazzano proprio perso
il conto la polica io sono solo morto
non so come ma non importa comunque nel
prossimo episodio vedrò di fare del rum
and the town che sono ancora due cose
diverse da quella di prima ho paura
effettivamente di scoprire che cazzo
sono però lo vedrà nel prossimo episodio
perché è però ci basta paranormale ne ho
abbastanza come sanitari che ha servito
è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e con ogni
video platea descrizione cioè non se l'è
prestiti scrive 13 rivediamolo così
unito bene ragazzi